Donuts from the sky, slowing down time with cold
brew and a not-so-secret Secret Santa. The rest of
the episodes are comedy gold, but we're ranking
just the cold opens for "Brooklyn Nine-Nine."
"Sure, sure, cool, cool, cool, cool, cool."
Generally, a cold open describes
any episode set-up that takes place
before the opening title. But
for the purposes of this list,
and in accordance with the unique way
"Brooklyn Nine-Nine" handles cold opens,
we've defined it as any pre-title skit that
has nothing to do with the rest of the episode.
Obviously, everything on this list
will make you at the very least smile,
but there's something particularly special about
this cold open from the episode "Beach House".
Having detected that Captain Holt may be pantsless
following an uncharacteristic lunch malfunction,
Jake decides to provide the squad with visual
proof. Cue several unsuccessful attempts to get
the Captain to stand up. Eventually Jake brings
in a replacement bowl of soup to entice him out
of his seat and Holt, of course, wanting
this to end, just admits to sitting in his
underwear. Jake celebrates his victory, but
also creates a second soup-pants interaction.
"Sir I need you to sign off on -"
"Look at us. Just three people with
pants on having a normal conversation."
"Yup. No story here."
While investigating a robbery at an
electronics store in the pilot episode,
Jake and Amy take very different approaches
to the case: Amy questions the owner,
and Jake distracts himself with
anything that happens to catch his eye.
Having arrived early and explaining
that he already found video footage
of the robbery thanks to a nanny
cam hidden within a teddy bear,
Jake just can't help himself, and makes the
bear hit on Amy, though not successfully.
"Detective Santiago! Don't walk away from me!"
This cold open gives viewers a rare
glimpse into the life of one Rosa Diaz,
who has never been known to dole out
any semblance of personal information.
Rosa's surprising desire to do something nice
by taking her boyfriend out to celebrate his
birthday spawns all sorts of weird
suggestions, but it's the drunk guy
in the holding pen who has the idea Rosa finds
most attractive ... for a few seconds, anyway.
"You can go to the top of the Empire
State Building, that's very romantic."
"Huh… maybe I will."
"You can pee on the WHOLE city from up there."
"Come on!"
When Charles treats the squad to some
cold brew, he unintentionally causes
a caffeine crisis so hilarious, there's
no way it wasn't going to make this list.
Captain Holt, Rosa, and Jake all somehow
forgot that cold coffee still has caffeine
in it and went to town on Charles' special brew
and the result is wonderful. From slow-mo Charles
to the double-speed trio, the writing,
editing, and performances are stellar,
as the caffeine fiends decide that there's
absolutely nothing wrong with them whatsoever.
"Captain how do you feel?"
"Great excellent amazing I feel better than
I've ever felt at any moment in my entire life."
"So we're all fine?"
[an exorbitant amount of 'Yeps."]
Jake and Holt's relationship has
always been the lynchpin of the show,
ranging from their weird father-son
dynamic to the incredible levels of
pettiness they sink to. This particular
cold open falls into the former category.
By Season 6, Holt is getting a little tired of
Jake's issues with tardiness. It's especially
galling when one considers the fact that
Jake's paramour is the frickin' queen of
being on time. In order to underline the
importance of timekeeping to his work-son,
Captain Holt devises a special kind of torture.
"Six years and no matter how hard I try I still
can't get you to understand the
importance of being punctual."
"Maybe you should just give up
and accept me for who I am?"
"No. I will break you. Right now."
"Oh."
Though he's never been one for any
kind of interpersonal touching,
Holt has painstakingly invented and rehearsed
a special, personalized handshake for every
member of the squad, and the copy guy.
It's the one thing Jake never saw coming.
It's no secret that Holt and Amy consider
themselves to be head and shoulders above
the rest of the squad. This superiority reaches
its zenith in the cold open to "Maximum Security."
After Holt gives them a brain teaser that will
reveal the location of a clandestine meeting,
most of the squad slowly trickles into the broom
closet. Jake is way too full of himself over his
victory, but does become suitably embarrassed when
Amy's love of adult puzzle camp is brought up.
"Doesn't she go to like an
adult puzzle camp every summer?"
"Yes but please don't bring that up,
I've been throwing out her mailers."
Perhaps the squad shouldn't be so quick
to mock Amy's summertime activities,
however. When they notice that Holt and Amy are
absent, they consider that they might be in the
wrong place. Hitchock and Scully's entrance
confirms it. Jake is unable to contain his
disappointment at discovering he's no smarter
than Hitchcock and Scully, and it's beautiful.
When an incredibly extravagant gift basket
arrives, the squad decides it absolutely must
be for them and they help themselves to the
basket's decidedly decadent contents. Gina,
always the wisest member of the team,
interrupts the feast by pointing out
that the basket is an obvious gift
to Holt from his husband Kevin.
Panic ensues, but Jake knows exactly how
to fix it. We cut to Captain Holt opening
an entirely re-built basket. The squad
waits with bated breath as he inspects the
replacement contents. A veritable smorgasbord
of shiny new stationery emerges — it's clear
the team has spared no expense to cover their
gluttonous tracks, and it works like a charm.
"...That man really knows me!"
This cold open has everything that makes
"Brooklyn Nine-Nine" great — Stephanie
Beatriz's complete commitment to deadpan
delivery, which remains intact as she
tosses donut holes at Andy Samberg, is
on fire here. With the writers apparently
unsatisfied with the already brilliant
bit, they take things one step further.
Jake misses catching a donut hole with his
mouth, and it goes sailing off the roof,
but it's only natural that the stray
pastry finds a home in Scully's mouth,
several floors below. Yup, Rosa is that
good, and fried desserts falling from
the sky is literally something that
must be a dream come true for Scully.
"It's finally happening!"
We're used to seeing Hitchcock bring pain
entirely on himself, but in this skit,
he's merely the innocent victim of
Jake's diabolical scheme to make the
older detective pee his pants. Well,
as innocent as Hitchcock gets, anyway.
Jake relies on the tried-and-true summer camp
method for his prank, leaving Hitchcock's hand in
a bowl of lukewarm water. Jake immediately brags
about his joke to the squad. When they check on
the pee progress, Hitchcock is somehow facedown
in the water. They grab him in the nick of time,
but in Rosa's opinion, this macabre turn
hugely improves the whole situation.
"I take it back, Jake, great prank."
When Hitchcock feels he's been badly treated at
the local coffee shop, he vents his frustrations
to the gathered squad members. He's about
as worked up as we ever see him, so clearly,
the slight has had a profound effect.
Who knew Hitchcock was so concerned with
how people see him? Maybe there's a soft
side to him that we haven't seen before?
Nope. Jake eventually interrupts Hitchcock
to tell him the reason for the odd treatment.
"Hey Hitchcock, your penis is hanging out."
"Oh, well that's a relief."
When Amy fails to appear at her desk at exactly
9 a.m, everyone comes up with outlandish theories
to explain her uncharacteristic tardiness.
Holt's contribution, however, clearly pushes his
imagination to its very limits. Having searched
his mind for the ultimate bizarre scenario,
he proudly proclaims his guess that she's
running late because of a long line at the bank.
Andre Braugher's deadpan delivery is amazing,
but he's actually saving the best for last.
When Amy walks in seconds later, the
squad demands that she explain herself.
"There was a problem at the bank…"
"Hot damn!"
Each member of the team picks a name for Secret
Santa in this holiday-themed cold open — except
for Rosa, who refuses to participate. What
follows belongs entirely to Andy Samberg,
thanks to his absolutely perfect delivery. Almost
instantly identifying everyone's Secret Santa,
Jake proceeds to humble-brag about his
skills. We even discover he's legally
changed his middle name to Sherlock,
for exactly this sort of situation.
Rather than being impressed by Jake's
antics, Holt speaks for the whole squad
and suggests something that shows their
displeasure at Jake ruining the game.
"...Should we draw the names
again and leave Jake out?"
"Yeah!"
"Nooo! Sherlock wants a present!"
There has never been, nor will there ever
be, a better cold open than this. As Jake
and a haunted-looking woman examine a lineup
of five men, she reveals that while she didn't
get a look at the criminal's face, she heard
him singing the Backstreet Boys' 1999 hit,
"I Want It That Way." Jake has them start singing,
and soon it becomes a full blown karaoke session.
The idea of having a police lineup sing
"I Want It That Way" might sound surreal,
but in practice, it's effortlessly perfect.
The musical magic is so powerful, in fact,
that Jake joins in and forgets
the reason for the singing.
"It was number five. Number
five killed my brother."
"Oh my God. I forgot about that part."